Speaker 1: Let's speak to some people from the
audience. We now take calls via Discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord. You can use Discord
to chat with other viewers and listeners and also
to talk to me. All right, let's start today
with Tyler from St. Louis, Tyler from St.
Louis. You were on the air with what's?
Speaker 3: How are you doing?
I'm doing good. Good. So the
question I want to ask is,
what is the path here going forward for
like the progressive caucus, because
in many ways I feel like, you know, burn it all
down. Everything like that. But then the other
thing is it's like, how? How long is it? How long
can they keep it up before it starts hurting us?
Speaker 1: Before what starts hurting us,
Speaker 3: oh, the infrastructure deal.
Speaker 1: You're saying it not being passed?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Oh, yeah. I mean, listen, I think
I don't think that the progressive, I think
there are some people within the progressive
caucus who really are like, burn it down type
acceleration tests. I don't think the progressive
caucus in general is going to ultimately say
no deal if it's not a perfect deal. I think the
progressive caucus overall understands you really
can't let the the perfect be the enemy of the
better than what we have. And I think ultimately,
if it doesn't happen, it's really going to be
because of Republicans. But you're you're thinking
that it might be the progressive caucus that
actually prevents infrastructure from being done.
Speaker 3: No, it's just kind of like how I
personally feel about it, like I'm like, split,
you know? I mean, I understand compromise and
everything like that. Yeah, but the thing is is.
You know, the deals being broken.
Speaker 1: Tyler, are you eating something
while you talk to me? Yeah, sorry about that.
You are. What are you eating out of curiosity?
Speaker 3: Just a
Speaker 1: sandwich sandwich. OK? All right. OK,
listen, Tyler, I understand your concern. I don't
think progressives are ultimately going to be the
roadblock for the infrastructure bill.
Speaker 3: Yeah, sure, yeah.
Speaker 1: All right, I'm going to let
you go your Discord's blinking now,
what's going on over there? I'm going to let you
get back to the sandwich, which seems delicious,
quite frankly. Why don't we go next to, oh, I
don't know. It's so hard to know where to go.
What about Sam from New York City?
Speaker 5:
Hey, how you doing? Oh, I just wanted to ask.
I know in the past I don't know if was a year
or two ago, maybe you had Stephanie Kelton on.
I was just wondering if with maybe some of the
recent stimulus packages, you've reconsidered your
feelings towards MMT or just sort of what your
general sense is towards modern monetary theory?
Speaker 1: Yeah, my my generals, we've interviewed
Stephanie a couple of times. My general
perspective on modern monetary theory right
now is that modern monetary theory makes a few
important points that should be considered. One
a government and country's budget is not analogous
to a household budget. It's not. And so we have to
use different terms. The analogies and
the comparisons to a household budget
don't make sense because households can't change
the money supply. That's number one. Number two,
modern monetary theory makes a fantastic
point, which is known outside of MMT as well,
that different types of deficit spending are
differently stimulative depending on what you're
spending the money on. That's the second important
thing. Beyond that, I'm not yet of the mindset
that the government can do absolutely anything
to the money supply with no impact whatsoever.
I don't think that's what modern monetary theory
is saying, but there are people who think that
that's what it's saying, and I think that is
not at all been been demonstrated. So that's
that's kind of where I am on MMT right now.
Speaker 5: Yeah, that's fair, and I think I
agree with you, I don't think real people who
have studied modern monetary theory would say
it's just about spending as much as you want
without consequences. It's basically like,
I guess my understanding is you can spend as
long as the resources are there, as long as the
physical and human infrastructure is there
to take on whatever spending, then you can
pretty much spend as much as you want because
you won't have excess money chasing scarcity
of goods or resources as long as you have enough
resources. I just I guess my problem is, I mean,
I just read Stephanie Cullen's book and still
don't think I have a firm understanding of MMT.
And so I wonder, like, I just think politically,
you know, not that we're anywhere close to
Democrats promoting modern monetary theory,
really. But I think there is so much promise in
it. But it would take a complete restructuring
of the framework of how we discuss deficits.
Speaker 1: Oh yeah. And remember that the debt
and deficit political football is one that both
Republicans and Democrats toss around to different
degrees. It's the Republicans who claim to care
about the deficit and then blow it up like it's
not a both sides thing in that sense. But both
parties still benefit from a lot of the discourse
around debt and deficit, and that makes it hard to
break the fact that that's how they're operating.
Speaker 5: Yeah. One thing I've thought about is,
you know, states don't have the same freedom to
deficit spend because they're not producing their
own currency, but if they could produce their
own sort of currency. I wonder if progressive
states I don't think this is constitutional, but
I think it would be an interesting experiment if,
let's say California created its own sort of
currency, could then deficit spend, implement
similar policies and have empathy and be able
to fund pretty substantial government projects?
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's that's seeming a little
out there and unlikely as far as I'm concerned.
But yeah, yeah, yeah, you know, it's an
interesting idea. All right, my friend.
Thank you for the call. I appreciate it.
Speaker 3: Thank you so much. All right.